我最爱的三杯去黄书果汁
跟我一样是大油皮,里面色动不动就是暗沉发黄
组研看起来非常没有气色解满
一定要是使喝完真的就感觉黄气退散
暗沉败白,组研情况下皮肤看起来也是很通透很干净的
这三款都很好喝,不需要你去语,然后又很方便有个破壁机就可以搞定
第一杯番茄胡萝卜汁,这杯对黄气中,老叶暗沉脱尾也有效
爱老叶的经常加班的姐妹一定要是是
反正我基本上老了,也第二天我就很喜欢炸这个河
用到的食材有这些
番茄红素是把我们居及自由机一颗氧化的高手
活了不素可以在身体里面转化成比A
帮皮膚形成代謝,赶走脸上的暗沉
明盟机的一定要去子,它不然就会有点苦
苹果是用来中口味道的,它会让我们准备变得更加清爽
我们把食材都放进破壁机里面再加一点点粉粉
这个甜菜跟粉,它是天然的不好
可以触级我们脸不寻馆的,让我们有内耳外透出红认感
屋董有它是优质指防,能够帮助这些指容性的一样吸收的更加充分
最后就是江黄粉加黑胡椒的这个黄金大大
江黄是把我们可以黄气的,黑胡椒可以让江黄素的吸收率翻倍
还可以折火血的感谢
早上来这么一杯,感觉一整天脸都在发光,坚持和素眼看起来就是很远静好气色
第二杯离枝炸炸凝,这一杯是满满的离析加上豐富的善视线位
喝完我们常味感觉超级通常,这论都感觉清快了
用到了食材游彩椒,巴勒,一把蓝美一点波罗,彩椒是隐藏的离析王者
很量超高,而且还特别的稳定
巴勒,它更是水果记得离析大户
善视线位也非常的多
美国家族我今天放的是蓝美,它富汗花金素
能帮皮膚几余氧化的伤害
锅罗的蛋白梅可以注销化,还可以让它准备的口味更清淺一些
它还能花将黄粉来一点,还可以再次加强面火效果
再来点黑胡椒,腐柱、姜黄素的吸收
满月梅粉不仅能帮皮膚黑氧驱黄,对咱们女生还特别好
再加一点点卡目国粉,这是一支的VC还量超高的Super属
它可以触仅交给合成让我们皮膚更紧吃
这一杯口感超级清爽等于是给皮膚和长道都来了个大小厨
第三杯满杯花青素升级版
这一杯真的就是花青素炸蛋
看的话你直接拉满,黄皮姐妹毕业合好吗
用到的食材有子干蓝,蓝美,当圣在加班的苹果
这杯子干蓝里面有满满的花青素,打几个样化
美国我还是用的蓝美,里面有花金素加VC加V1
三重防护,三圣更是花青素炸蛋,巨黄提亮效果很强
苹果能增加一点点的甜味,更好入口
我们还是再来一点点卡目国粉,VC还量超高的粉分
不堵油,它是提供優正纸防的
让我们适进去的黑氧成分,能够被身体更好的利用
最后依旧是姜黄和黑胡椒
这一杯喝下去真的感觉皮膚的红卓感
正在被满满的竞化,黄气敲敲退散
坚持和素炎都可以白身小的泡
这三杯的话不需要添添和,我一般一周三次刺
我一般是喜欢早上的空复和,我觉得这样子身体的吸收率更好一线
如果是常为不好的姐妹,你们可以在饭后大概一个小时之后再和
记得喝到这些配合出门一定要做好防晒